one of the most striking features of the
world around us is the remarkable
diversity
that is observed within communities
whether you're looking at
the community of trees in a rainforest
of
animals coexisting in the savannah or at
the microscale of microbial communities
coexisting in the soil my name is jeff
gore
i am an associate professor in the
physics department at mit the
massachusetts institute of technology
i am an experimental physicist
interested in trying to understand
the dynamics of complex communities of
biological organisms
and in particular laboratory microcosms
little worlds in the lab of
microorganisms interacting
and trying to understand what is it that
controls
the diversity of those communities
the coexistence of so many species in
natural communities
is a challenge to understand because we
often think about
some notion of the survival of the
fittest that
the species that is perhaps most adapted
to some environment
should perhaps be able to drive all the
other species there extinct
and if that's what's going on then when
you go out and you go on a walk
what you would observe is just a small
number of species in that environment
whereas in fact when you go on a hike
through the rainforest you see a
remarkable diversity of species that
seem to be able to
survive together and coexist
indefinitely
i think that my background in physics
has influenced me in a number of
different ways in terms of how i think
about these problems
of ecosystem dynamics and the diversity
of communities
but perhaps the most important way in
which it's influenced my work
is that in physics there's a tradition
of a very strong
dialogue between theory and experiment
where
theory often guides which measurements
or experiments
one does but then also the experiments
will
guide future theories this complex
interplay between theory and experiment
is i think a really fun way of doing
science but also a way of doing science
that provides a lot of insight
into what's going on as we try to
learn about the rules governing say
microbial community diversity but
there's always a question about the
relationship between
what we discover as compared to the
dynamics of communities at the macra
scale
between treaties or animals and i from
my perspective
i think that some of the lessons that we
learn for microbial communities
will actually have general implications
for
other forms of communities but at the
same time it's likely they're going to
be some differences
and actually both the similarities and
the differences are things that we're
excited to try to understand